[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I made you look oh my goodness welcome
back to the break room our daily live
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy fandom news you need to know and
boy is this a day for nerdy fandom news
coming up on the show today we got all
that lucasfilm and Marvel announcements
coming out of ccxp we have our reaction
to that amazing Guardian of the Galaxy
vol 3 trailer and Jay our boy Jay has
something he needs to get off of his
chest it's a big day for everyone you
see this chest though wait you gotta pay
attention I've been working on this
chest a lot a lot of good push-ups a lot
of good you know I'm just saying yeah
that's Jay Washington if you didn't know
you didn't know I'm here hey guys now
you know he's been working on his chest
and working on his chest is koi John
uh it's a wild uh wild day out there
folks if you don't know there's been
news dropping all day uh thanks mostly
in part to this little Comic-Con little
Comic-Con they're having down in Brazil
right now showed up uh and he brought
receipts with him uh we have so much to
talk about we're gonna talk about all
that great stuff uh we want to remind
you guys there's another Comic-Con yeah
probably a little larger than what we
saw in Brazil maybe even bigger news who
knows uh but uh this weekend in LA
a very serious big news breaking
Comic-Con listen simulu will be there
I'm gonna get him on the break room yes
you think Seymour you're the Marquee
guest you're gonna be the Marquee guest
in the break room by the way we're gonna
be there and if you ever want your chest
signed by me now's your chance that is
your chance uh the break room will be
live at La Comic-Con uh on Sunday
that's a separate event at the Marriott
are you going to determine who exactly
gets their chest side because it's gonna
be the robe chest it's gonna be
something we will sign any chest you
present yeah I don't care and I'm
talking treasure chests for those of you
that are sickos out there bring your
lock boxes to me and I'll sign them
he'll risk his hand and he'll sign a
mimic uh
excuse me what I've seen it I was here
it's happened it wasn't pleasant for
everyone
we don't have any official Redemption
today but uh if you're sending any super
chats you got questions or your own
thoughts about what we've seen out there
already today send them in we'll try and
get them all in the air today we've
already been getting some trash bag sent
in a great Super Chat saying listening
while working outside in the rain glad
to have you guys I Can't Stand the Rain
uh it might be raining soon here in our
secret location we'll never know uh uh
we also get in super chats from Bucky
Barnes ATL he missed you Tommy wow uh
and we already ran a poll I can't
believe we did it already uh what did
you guys think about the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 trailer most of you
thought ah wait do they get a quote from
wired Max I think I think I got that
right 20 of you said you haven't seen it
yet I hope you already caught up on it
yeah folks uh we we filmed a little live
reaction here in the office because we
couldn't believe that this was all
happening today uh let's show you what
happened when we watch it really for the
first time this was not faked it was
actually the first time we saw it
we were gone for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
[Music]
don't forget
where we came from
[Music]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
that's great
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
in a beautiful sky
[Music]
[Applause]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
that's just sad six months I swear we
filmed a reaction for that but someone
deleted it I don't know who but it was
deleted it was annoyed it was the noise
it was annoyed at all costs
but let's hear you guys as quick
reactions to that I I know you've seen
it and you just saw it again but uh what
what were like your initial reactions to
seeing that what blew you away the most
I I personally think that if this sticks
The Landing like it looks to be this I
think in my opinion it'll be the best of
the Marvel trilogies because I I would
put Guardians 2 over cat First Avenger
which makes it Trilogy okay
when you do it that way two over Iron
Man 2 Guardian two of her first avenger
Guardians there you go therefore this is
the greatest Trilogy of the Marvel
Trilogy Thor isn't even a Trilogy
anymore though or the quadrility itself
yeah he's making some choices but uh I
think personally what James Gunn's been
able to do with manipulating our
emotions to a level that has been at a
nine throughout the trilogy is now gonna
go on 11. like this looks so
gut-wrenching so funny like it's it's
all of the the Masterwork of him showing
us how to make us feel that trailer is
more emotionally impactful than movies
I've seen I'm so invested in these
characters we've lived them for five
hours now plus their own like teen
movies and stuff the amount this is
gonna hurt when they all die I like I'm
not I'm not stop it
say that first of all put some respect
on Blade's name the all-time Trilogy
second of all the fake out everything
okay okay you just walked in we just got
married
he's wearing a wire he's wired he's the
fans he's the fans all right uh uh the
fake out of of fake Earth turning into
what I just assumed was the island of Dr
Moreau BoJack Horseman it's live action
I loved it oh man a little dodgeball
humor getting pelted in the face what's
funnier than a kid getting knocked over
by a playground ball I dare you to tell
me call it if you know Colin if you know
uh yeah incredible stuff I mean I did
this from the first movie when a
digitally created raccoon in a digital
created tree man made me both cry yes I
was like well this guy can do pretty
much whatever he wants with these
characters uh it looks like he's doing
that and I you know it doesn't look
great for a lot of our heroes man look
that that one scene of quail screaming
yeah I mean that that's the equivalent
to last year with Spider-Man of him in
the rain again which turned out to be
the death of Batman this is you know
do they kill Gamora again I mean we've
all pretty much assumed Rocket's done
Rockets out of here why are we so his
bedtime because James because if you
don't if you want to get the emotion out
of everybody Drax will make you hurt
Roxy Rocket's death will break everybody
yeah but why do we have to break
everybody because because you know why
what has been the theme of this phase
this is the next phase this this and the
next phase are all bleeding to the same
thing grief no not lizard people yet
this is grief trauma trying to overcome
it and going forth with life in the most
heartbroken way
and we're kicking off phase five with
this you got Kang about to kill a bunch
of people it's about to be a lot of
death before you get to the major thing
right so I think this is like again like
Corey said this is James Gunn showing
you I'm gonna show you a complete Arc of
characters from literal beginning to end
and he's about to show it and his
culmination of it is going to have
everybody leaving out here
James good no more what's he got coming
with DC that's literally how we gonna be
yeah well we have we have lots to say
about this Guardians trailer but there's
so much to cover today we're gonna get
back to this Guardian stuff soon uh Mike
whatever sending in a Super Chat saying
rocket dying better be a misdirect or
I'm going to be I'm with you Mike
whatever like whoever Mike whenever
we're gonna talk more Guardians we're
going to talk about some of the other
news that came out today uh we did we
learned that Mando season three has a
release date March 1st 2023. what's
what's gonna happen to q1 guys come on
come on I'm really stalling come on
Wookie freaks make your voices
Wilkie freaks want some more Wookie
leaks baby right uh I saw the Empire
strips back last night exceptional is
that what they keep advertising to me on
Facebook yeah dude I've heard it's
incredible it's like it's incredible
it's it's in La maybe we get the whole
family yeah
like I just want to see the deaf stuff
dude there's a lot
I'm gonna re-watch those shows
online movies for me like it's a special
time a lot of this is
more than you ever little sexy ass
Stormtroopers prepare yourself
for absolutely uh folks the other big
trailer today Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny we get a name we've got the
dog we got a poster we got a release
date he's coming out June 30th
it's the dial the thing around his neck
he has to hit if he falls in the shower
don't know anything about a dial on a
phone
I think it's a sundial we have a little
Quick Clip of that trailer of course
let's show you that
I miss the desert
I miss the sea
I miss sweet
morning
[Music]
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us I don't believe
in magic
but a few times in my life
thank you
for seeing things
things I can't explain
[Music]
the dial of Destiny it looks so good it
doesn't look so good did you finally
kill Indy ah I mean yes maybe he's done
falling over for us uh like I mean
seriously there's death yeah like let's
just think about it you know we all like
no he can't go but Indiana Andy's dying
Rockets dying everybody's done what's
wrong with this you get a casket
everyone gets memorials like I mean it
would make sense uh this is of course
the trailer that a few of us got to see
a d23 that was like okay so that's what
that was the show I don't think it was
any different I gave you a couple
different shots the underwater shot I
think was a little extended and I do
think that the uh technology looks a
little better that looks insane like
that looks like Indiana on a horse still
looks a little bit I mean but that
that's unmasked but I couldn't remember
the line she says at the end where she's
like I'm as this is my goddaughter or
something like that I don't remember
we're badly related uh at d23 people are
awesome cheering so loud I don't
remember to the point where every single
other panel referenced it no
[Music]
Ludacris says whips and chains handcuffs
smack a little booty with that bug
scream hell I mean Dracula man I get my
I'm sorry a big mads Mickelson stand
glad to see him yeah uh you know I mean
this has all the indut tropes you got
temples you got Nazis you got whips you
got guns you got chases nothing like an
Indiana Jones punch
I think he's got his own guy yeah here's
my question got his punch sound how much
how much politicking did Harrison Ford
try to do unsuccessfully to have Indiana
wear a hoop earring oh I do want to see
his diamonds
this is
Incredible movies
thunderballs these my hoes
different flavor all together this is my
bottom chick Valentina
Harrison Ford please we got standards
please help us uh I mean you pick up a
good point Jay like Harrison Ford died
like Indiana showing Indy dying in the
movie I don't know I want him to ride
off into the sunset I want so you want
the next movie is just all of a sudden
reference Indiana died or which because
you know there are always people who are
going to be we gotta see there's it
never fails anytime you say someone died
in a movie the a subsequent movie you're
like can we see what happened I think
there's a certain closure that Harrison
Ford's seeking out that I that I think
is interesting like he wanted to you
know have Han Solo have his end I feel
like this is a very similar yeah and
honestly I think his decision to do
Thunderbolts is more of a Legacy
character because I think what they got
him to agree to is probably scan him
mocap him Red Hulk they own the identity
of the imagery the likeness of so I
don't think he stays Harrison Ford that
long and then Red Hulk oh yeah so all of
this to me seems like a guy that's like
I want my grandkids to have money
forever and like I respect that like
dudes just like make sure the Fords you
know
Santa Monica Mountains that's it because
he's been so much more like emotionally
available in press releases and like
when he came out of d23 he was so like
giving an open I just feel like Harrison
Ford's at the point in his career where
he just wants to like hey I love you
guys you're my fans let me just let me
know
because you know every Indiana Jones
press junket he does now someone's gonna
try to ask him about Thunderbolts and I
cannot wait and I've seen it on Twitter
and everything is the truth to hear
Harrison Ford go I really don't give a
[ __ ] just and then just move on and you
like uh does he not care about this
movie
I don't want them here to talk about
Indiana damn it all right yes Lance no
but friends much like gun like I feel
like he's trapped talking about DC for
Guardians I do hope they that like this
generation especially is is so Marvel
driven not appreciating necessarily what
Indy was so I'm hoping that he does get
to be Indiana Jones actually One Last
Time versus like hey you're gonna be a
Thunderbolts like I hope the the
journalists give him
yeah but I thought he had it in Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull and clearly wasn't
happy with that and I think a lot of
fans weren't happy with that whereas
mutt in this movie that's what I want to
know uh what happens if he's not happy
with this though I think I think he's
got to be he seemed very sure okay 23.
he made the statement I'm not falling
down for you guys anymore okay and he
seemed very much like choking back tears
he was like this one's good yeah okay
okay he came out literally like choking
my shoes the whole time and all of us
were like well Dad like it was a very
good
well we don't know it's right before he
went on stage he got a very upsetting
phone call
Harrison
we've uh we've got some bad news about
the FTX Exchange
in it but it looks like you're gonna
have to be red hawk after that's why he
signed up yeah that's why we didn't hear
it I didn't want to do this he looked at
fighting he's like okay but also he like
loves it I'll show everything
holy fans oh I'll show the red hulkit
only hulks does not need that but I I
feel like uh he also like his reference
for James Mangold feels like like
mangled loves this character uh I was at
the Ford Ferrari Premiere and Harrison
Ford was there and like very proud of
what they'd already developed for that
and that was years ago that was what
2019 when that movie came out yeah so
like this was a property that James
bengold was courting Harrison for to the
point like he was at his Premiere
talking about India and it was really
special to see like he looks rejuvenated
in the franchise so this to me is best
case scenario I love when a franchise
gets its Creed you know it gets it to do
yeah but we talk about mango what was
the send-off he did that broke everybody
as well remember Logan broke us off one
word daddy Logan broke everybody so
again there's a possibility with his
send off into the sunset for this we can
be broken with the death of Indiana
Jones somehow and his goddaughter
daughter takes over his legacy right
mangold's just out there killing him I
mean Disney and mango that that shot of
revealing a young a younger whatever the
bag is great I mean there's a lot of
theory the dial of Destiny we were kind
of saying that's a weird name but I
think it fits in the UVA of like in the
woods say it again wow
[Music]
why Destiny's the end yes like that's
what's your destiny your destiny is to
die doing what you love doing being an
archaeologist and being in all these
things your destiny is to pass your
legacy on you can't spell destiny
without die style
nah all right I do love the line though
it's like I don't believe in magic I
mean if anyone in the world oh my God
you've seen men's faces
the thing that moves me that most of the
trailer is old Sala yeah yeah Jonathan
Rhys Davies back again maybe problematic
we don't know we don't know do you guys
think this is a time travel movie that's
a lot of the theory out there what are
these are these flashbacks is he going
back through time
I think it's gonna be a greatest hits of
like indie's adventures and how each of
those who starts the movie like with his
legs across the chair hello everyone
I've had a great time these last 40
years making these Indiana Jones let's
look back on some of my classic scrapes
is that like Slumdog Millionaire where
it's like all these moments these little
games
I think it's gonna be like different
things that he's uh you know
architecture
archaeological discoveries words
but he he they might lead to one thing
so we might have to go through a
greatest hits clip show and now that's
what I call it and you know what that
would do that actually would that
actually would lessen the workload that
Harrison Ford would have to have in this
movie because if they're doing it if
it's a young like what they did for Luke
Skywalker in Mandalorian with the
younger actor and they're putting their
face on it yes so it's not a it's not
shaved him it's not the Irishman we have
an old man yeah
[Applause]
rheumatoid arthritis at 18. we can we
can bash the Irishman rightfully so
deservedly so for so many things but the
sword that it fell on for us is it will
forever have improved the Aging by
ensuring that a younger actor does the
body works right well you know well the
face can be the older actor the Irish
through paychecks the Irishman uh swam
so we could run I don't know that's
right metaphor goes yeah the Irishman
painted houses so that we can paint
Mansions Joe Ralston Ralston said in
that Super Chat thing Indy knows old men
don't fight fair that whip in the room
scene I mean that that is great uh
indeed yeah he knows the old men don't
fight fair no one fights Fair that's
what makes Indiana Jones uh movies great
uh uh Jacob Smith also sending in a chat
I think maybe the dial reveals times of
his life that he can relive but at a
cost like he can maybe go back but each
one takes a little bit away that's the
true but every time you time travel
though right that is always the Trope
where if you go back into because time
traveling is op right you gotta have a
way to like there's gotta be a cost yeah
and I kind of hope it's not time travel
because I like with we learn lesson with
aliens like I like when India but it's
time traveling it's hard to say grounded
with a new and like you know Temple of
Dooms out there but around it grounded
grounded in Indiana Jones yep he's a
grounded character okay lips forever in
a cage
yes
it will bring forth eternal life okay
remind me of you know a lot of people go
to a fancy building every Sunday to
swear allegiance to some of these things
all right okay okay and remind me of the
rules of the Last Crusade because they
crossed the threshold the immortality
goes away right you weren't allowed to
bring the Grail past the threshold but
yes I think also leaving the temple you
lose the power it's like the cornfield
it's been so long but yeah I think
you're right because in order to live
forever we have to stay in the cave
which is not a good idea folks that's
not a good deal I don't know
caves are nice now now but not them give
me a nice cave with a Sealy prostrate
give me a nice with a Casper mattress
thank you what about a helix with a
helix mattress give me a helix mattress
hey John edit this all out let me start
over yeah with a helix mattress and I'll
stay there for a lifetime you know
what's terrible is that your choice of
betting depending on what you can
pronounce in the cave yeah yeah I want
to see me
give me a sleeping bag give me a
sleeping bag I'm good give me a cop uh
palette uh Eric bass and Whitney van
laningham there they have their reaction
to that very trailer out on the channel
now make sure you check that out after
you watch the break room and you like
and you subscribe to the channel uh and
we'll have a full breakdown uh of that
trailer that'll be out I believe
tomorrow or this weekend at some point
uh Eric's also reacted to the uh
Guardians of the Galaxy trailer and
we'll have a breakdown for that trailer
things shifted a lot today folks we had
a business we were like oh my God I have
a lot to talk about now now we're just
here I had stuff I was giving off my
chest today keep them on your chest
please uh attend these ccxp also got to
watch the opening minutes of Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania we'll have a recap
of that footage for you guys tomorrow
they didn't release any footage they
released kind of a retrospective also
crazy to y'all that like we're so used
to San Diego Comic-Con colleagues being
the big thing that everybody releases
and drops but now you really have to
look forward to ccxp I love this is like
the third year third time they've
dropped major stuff at that Brazilian
comment let's make it Global you know
like it doesn't have to be once a year
in an American city no I'm not saying it
doesn't have to be I wasn't I'm sorry I
didn't I didn't mean that debate I'm
just saying I love you see this you want
to get myself get on in there all right
come on
now I I just like the fact that you
never know maybe France Comic-Con Comic
Con Francois will be next year we'll get
like an Iron Man 5 trailer
film special Bachelor the leaper takes
France yes
he is so obsessed with a bat Rock the
leap he's so good man
you give me the stunt team from Winter
Soldier and a GSP led backrock the
leaper
films
and Thunderbolts guaranteed yes
you need someone to LEAP all this will
take is a leap of faith just all the
time back it here but I will Quantum
Leap into the situation pardon me you've
been waiting so long it's a leap year
you better bend over so I can play a
little LeapFrog they wait until the next
February 29th and that's the year they
do that special
presentation on February 29th I'm coming
in this office by myself turning over
the lights and the cameras and just
start streaming they're like why is Jay
just sitting here smoking a cigarette
well Collision this is why I'm not Kevin
foggy because I would green like that
tomorrow and then it goes away for four
years yeah you can only watch it once
every four years that's a great idea we
should make an nft about that those
markets are doing well right
they do all the time bargain prices uh
in conjunction with this uh footage they
they showed a scene of Ant-Man and was
quantum Mania at ccxp they put out kind
of like a little retrospective Trail to
get your hype there's not really any new
shots uh from from Ant-Man and was
quantum any and that but there is like a
new off-screen line of dialogue where
they're playing with that final line
where where Kang says we see him say
Ant-Man but in the lead up to this one
in the dark uh instead of of Kang saying
what'll it be Ant-Man he says now you're
out of your league Ant-Man I would love
if it's just because they're not sure
yet like they're just they're just I
think that's what it is they're like
they got options guys we don't know how
this conversation's gonna go what if
it's all the throwaway lines and none of
these lies are in the choice
I'm your dad and when we hear the
theater it's going to be a momentous
moment and they're giving us the alts I
think they filmed some like you know
neutral lines and in the moment he's
gonna be like I've got your daughters
Tommy you probably agree with me over
Court I think this is when King is
showing uh Ant-Man this is a Quantum
porn yeah
look what I can do with all these
micronauts you see this oh my god
without you ever even noticing you see
what the fingers do yes that's no sling
ring all right let's box something else
someone's gotta save this the show and
it's not gonna be me but I do think uh
the Ant-Man retrospective does also lend
itself to him die it feels very much
like let's go through our dreams again
that's what these two phases are grief
loss and Trauma Thatcher's gonna take
over the Ant-Man mantle and she's gonna
get stepped on by in front he gonna get
stepped on in front of his daughter and
I honestly think she needs to have that
moment because we've already got a dad
and Thor taking care of his daughter
she's an older daughter I think she
becomes a hero when Paul sacrifices
himself right not not Ant-Man Paul Rudd
sacrifice I just got my daughter back in
real life can just step on them Baskin
always finds out I mean you know I just
back in he's got to cut costs he's got
too many hats as long as they put a
giant Granite statue of him in front of
the basket
at the bottom of that statue I need to
hear of all the people who died and the
construction of this 31 stories all I
know is they can't keep killing all
these Heroes because going to Disneyland
is just Macabre yeah
Tony and Natasha walking around and then
by Panthers walking around I'm like
these guys are dead
Valhalla all represented you're on web
slingers and he's like call Tony Stark
and I'm like who's got a phone in the
coffin oh my God
it's getting dark phase five getting
real dark so it's like The Sopranos ride
we have stayed we have Jay here on the
show which is always a treat but we have
to take special advantage of the
situation because there was also a
teaser trailer release today for
Transformers rise of the Beast this was
not part of CCX people it was so
expertly dropped by Paramount today
right before all of this uh and I think
I think they were hoping to get swept up
in this new cycle nice really it worked
here we are uh Jay you are you know the
most about Transformers yes than anyone
I know yeah so I want to get a little
bit of analysis on this trailer so again
I've always said to everybody when they
said this movie was happening if you go
back to the old Michael Bay Transformers
films you're not a fan let's just be
honest they're visually exhausted
they're exhausted then you get Bumblebee
and you're brought back into things
you're like okay this is what they look
like what I wanted and that's all the
same universe right it's not yes and no
it's probably like a prequel because he
drives off as the new Camaro at the end
yes he does yeah but we don't kind of
this bumblebee was always on Earth and
Optimus comes in right okay so but when
you find out this one is happening
you're like okay we already struggled
with yeah I was doing research on this
actually oh oh yeah apparently they shot
that ending so that they if like the
movie didn't work out and they didn't
couldn't make sequels they were like oh
it was a prequel oh that's so funny
because they never said the time right
intended to be a reboot
oh
cool also I'm glad you're here because
you're in blue and we didn't have that
color represented
where that all that craziness in Chicago
didn't happen thank God Transformer I
saw half of Chicago
was the one was probably the most
disappointing thing because everyone is
a kid or you saw you love the Dinobots
is that Fallen Kingdom pretty much sword
yes the sword and all that and I'm gonna
ride Grimlock Marky Mark is a scientist
yes and Grimlock never would let Optimus
Prime ride him they're both equal
they're equal Alphas four lack of better
words but then you hear Stephen cable
Jr's taking us over and also it's like
all right what are they doing in this
one so now they're bringing the beast in
you're like huh cause like I've been
telling everybody you go back to Beast
Wars where you get the the animals you
get Optimus primal Chi tour rat trap you
get rhinox you get Megatron as a purple
T-Rex which for some reason works okay
you get wasp and if you get Dinobot
which his weird name was just Dinobots
Dinobot but then you hear that so you're
like okay you think these characters so
now you're still kind of hesitant you
have the low belief in Stephen cable Jr
because of creed and everything else you
get some pictures you're like okay and
then this drops and it changes
everything also the casting like the
people in this as well as the like a
below and above the line are all
incredible yeah it's assembled like it's
not a light film I feel like they're
really investing in this reboot yeah uh
Stephen cable Jr is such a passionate
filmmaker I can't imagine his dedication
would like he wouldn't do this halfway
like the way he treated Creed was like
my God so to follow up Creed you need
something like I wouldn't have done
Transformers as a false Creed unless I
was like obsessed I was sure I can do it
the way I wanted to do it and put out
what I wanted to and so the very first
Transformer you see being Optimus primal
and the way he looks because he's not
even just regular little gorillas he's
massive he's fighting Joe Young yes and
then but just to make it so the much the
best to have Primal interacted with
prime I know I was lying
all right so we're sorry just didn't go
just interrupt as a person who's lost
his way in the Transformers Universe
yeah Michael Bay
Stan whitwicky Megan Fox
Camaro these are not part of those he's
not part of this at all there's no
chance Megan Fox watches a car in this
movie no
not at all okay
you know what I don't want it then I did
see a cheetah Galloping around it like
that and a very sexy Transformer lady RC
and RC from goes back to the G1 cartoons
if anybody remembers she was a big part
of that and she was even a major part of
the Transformer Headmaster Series where
they would take that's where I was kind
of hoping they would go with this
franchise but keep it out of Michael
Bay's hands but nonetheless to see cheat
or see rhinox to see Optimus Prime well
to see Optimus Prime to see Bumblebee
potentially get he [ __ ] ripped off to
see Mirage finally be Mirage
the Porsche that makes the copies of
himself to see Mirage be himself just in
this minute and so odd teaser trailer
you get more amped up of what this is
and again we were talking about this
earlier 2023 is set to be a phenomenal
year film so it's going to be like every
week every week so if you don't have one
of those like uh amca list or if you
know or if you're like me who's begging
Paramount Studios right now on camera
please have me at everything for this
movie I mean have Jay at this Premiere
please come on minimum I will I will
dress up like a little pink Corvette and
let Jay Drive me around as a Transformer
if you invite him but I don't even have
to see the movie he can park me outside
and then let the valets me riding around
together
I can guarantee you they've never
received such an offer like all I know
ain't nobody gonna ask me about the [ __ ]
hey you want to ride Tommy back told us
to the premiere
I think it's happening
like a Transformer that does the like
I'm a Transformers
so Megatron in this one has to go yes
like the Beast Wars because he always
had a certain yes okay juggle buttons
make sure those pesky maximals are you
know there's certain things you kind of
want to see but if you don't so far
you're not it's not things that look
that bad right you know I was thinking
Paramount's in a really good spot post
Top Gun right so they've got like a
really strong franchise they put out
Sonic 2 and Top Gun too and Sonic 3 is
about so like they're I really think
Paramount is the next wave of the IP
that gets to be its own film yes
rebooting this franchise seven versions
of Yellowstone on TV hey did we all
forget that we were supposed to get to
Hasbro Universe at one point
they were talking about putting all of
them together Brianna might show up who
knows what might happen My Little Pony
with the Transformers dog that's it yeah
then that's when if Tommy comes in
looking like My Little Pony well and has
that's why I'm Galloping also owns
wizards of the company but Dungeons and
Dragons
because right now in Wizards of the
Coast they have uh Transformers in Magic
the Gatherings yeah it's very insane
stuff uh yeah so so Jay you you think
this looks good A Transformers fan yes
or from a fan who was again I you know
you see the first Transformers movie and
you're like okay because you first hear
oh real quick when Michael Bay said they
will not shapeshift because that was the
big when you tell me you're giving me
Shockwave and he doesn't turn into a
small Boombox I mean sound wave excuse
me and you're like that's yeah that was
his thing everything had to fit yeah
sound wave whatever then you go further
you're like oh this is all these other
ones I was like that's no whatever and
then like I said we go further and
further the Bumblebee changes things and
then you have some hope and now this you
have hope I like their transforming in
this trailer the transforming is so
complicated so it's cleaner just rule of
three is let me button this
Transformer's shirt up a little bit even
though at the end of Bumblebee Bumblebee
turns into the Camaro it's still it's a
different Camaro yeah not the Camaro
that Stan Whit Ricky finds at the
beginning of Transformers one never
forget are you sure about that yeah
never forget an Ironman at the end of
The Incredible Hulk with the with the
post credit scene with Tony Stark that
was not originally there right they
added that if iron if Iron Man doesn't
do good that post-credits scene never
happens right well if ifs and Bots were
candy enough to be Christmas every day
well folks we want to talk more about
the Guardians of the Galaxy trailer but
first we have to let you know that our
friends over at epic hero shop have a
cool new product they're calling their
Converse yeah there's batteries on it
he's got a contest get out of the way
it's Convent it's made for wearing to
Convention oh convinced no that's the
kind of car like La Comic-Con this
weekend or San Diego Comic-Con our Star
Wars celebration or WonderCon or if
you're in Brazil ccxp whatever uh facial
creams to your friends and then they buy
a little more and then they buy a little
more uh whatever you want whatever you
want to attend you can wear this vest
too uh on the shoulder panels of each
vest are various words translated into
what content our best Klingon Valerian
cindarian and Kryptonian the vest is
perfect for sticking pins and patches on
which is what we're going to be doing
all week here on the break room uh you
can enter to win this exact vest
including your the pins and patches you
want a pins and Patch do you have a
Brazzers patch
uh you can enter your email at Epic
heroshop.com
be respectful confess contest again
that's epic heroshop.com
contest that link will also be in the
description show this video they have
tons of cool pens that you can add on
this fast too hey Brandon mind if I take
this next one you check this next one
Tom you know it's been no secret I've
been missing from the break room for the
last three days and that's because I was
a little under the weather I had a
little bit of a sore throat stuffy nose
and chest but let me tell you something
to help me out from my illness athletic
greens and we want to thank them for
sponsoring the break room this week
right it's the holidays and most of us
aren't eating great I for one personally
ate my weight and stuffing last week
might have something to do with it
stuffing's kind of light yeah guess what
I did it They begged me not to I was
like a stuffing Kool-Aid man I walked
into the room going oh
uh anyway we need some help to fill in
the gaps in our diet and ag-1 from
athletic greens is our preferred option
mine specifically one scoop a day and a
glass of water and you're covering your
vitamin and nutrient needs you're
investing in an all-in-one nutritional
insurance for less than the price of a
latte and if you're like me you drink
your coffee black still cheaper than
that not a latte all right listen to me
I was sick as a dog and now I'm fit as a
fiddle social Cato keto potato paleo
vegan vegan dairy free and gluten free
your subscription comes with a year's
supply of vitamin D heard of it which is
important to add in those winter months
when we go get as much sun why reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit athletic
greens slash break room again that is
athletic green slash break room take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
thank you athletic greens you nurse me
back to health like a little bitty baby
travel packs I was just on a trip to see
my family I had them every day they were
like this hippie from California what
are you drinking I was chasing every
meal for the last week I just need some
athletic greens which y'all tell them to
be honest in L.A there's so many like
nutrient based things that you want to
actually feel the difference
with athletic greens we don't need you
to get any strong I drink it every
morning Instagram filter this isn't real
I'm gonna poison Your Greens
now that we it was me we got our
Vitamins out of the way folks so let's
talk about our desserts all right this
fifth Guardians trailer I really did not
think it would come out today we heard
rumors of it I was like I gotta wait
till January yeah we were doubting
Thomas we were like no way it's coming
out this early uh uh for the holidays
let's talk about a couple of things in
this trailer that that the fake out at
the beginning is okay because we just
had the holiday special we saw the Bowie
come to to L.A we're like oh they're
coming back Peter's coming back to Earth
again and he's been here during game I
don't know if that counts I don't think
he went to a mall or anything while he
was here uh and then it's kind of a fake
out right it's this weird
anthropomorphic Animal Planet is this
the high evolutionaries I assume it's
his name play place
though it's so weird what if he's
setting up that is his goal so he wants
to do this like if like we want to play
with creatures that are similar in
nature so you it seems like a predator
that toys with his food we see that girl
running around that weird yeah
yeah so like maybe he makes a little
like planet-sized dollhouse why does he
look like Suburbia well why did they
dressed in dungarees and flannels I
don't know like why are we all gonna
dress so Suburban sorry it looks like
somebody named Donald has at least
listen my uncle Donald loves it Lisa
says Kia Sportage and he has a great
time I mean to me it's a very comic
Booky thing yeah right this that is so
commentary like oh it's just like yours
but everyone's an animal yeah and I
think that's the real reason is the high
evolutionary would want something
similar but also aesthetically we got
that moment of like and also our
familiarity we're gonna be more
empathetic to creatures that we can
identify with so when they die yeah but
also we've seen and we've seen various
creatures that sort of look
anthropomorphic like those throughout
the entire Guardians franchise yeah so
it's going to come to play yeah it's not
the first time we've seen them they
touched that Panda man I swear
I mean even in the Christmas special
there was like Creations that might have
got high evolutionaries well let's not
forget that I mean I'll never get over
Doctor Strange just dropping a bull man
on us like they're like it's no big deal
this guy yeah he's gonna say nothing
replacement right here no he just he's
just working you know saying we got a
W-2 form he gonna fill out his paperwork
and everything you know he's a he's a
tax credit so he work here now we also
had the shot a couple shots of like
those Rings yeah fleshy materials
calamari and some calamari rings I mean
to me it reminds me a lot of what
they've been showing in Ant-Man and the
watch Quantum Mania with a lot of like
weird rings and I almost wondered is
this like are they super small somewhere
oh and this is like an organic thing
reminded me sort of knit of a leer
remember oh yeah yeah the Ring's a bit
Rings the star the dying star that makes
uh Thor's hammers yeah it makes
Stormbreaker it looked like that like
you said but fleshy I was like that's
what it felt like to me I don't know
it's anybody watching if it felt like
that but I was like I could agree could
it be some could that be like a cellular
structure I definitely felt like it was
a high evolutionaries work whether or
not that was like that black ooze we see
later on whether that's like you know
the going it might be a flashback to
Rocket being created also that might be
yeah because we're gonna go on that
Journey it's gonna be hard we are going
on that journey and I just want to point
out to our viewers do not Google flesh
planning
no place you never wanted to go please
Friedman I gotta say is Gamora working
for higher level high evolutionary I
think that's a great theory of how she
is well I mean like we know she's off on
her own right they're out there Guardian
the Galaxy and she's got to be doing
something and she's bad right she's bad
Gamora she kind of like turns on her dad
at the very end of of end game but like
is everything all right he's still he's
still processing
I mean it's a great film it's about 46
minutes
and life is created in it I think or at
least the process was it a rumor or I
thought Gamora was like a ravager now oh
yeah right wait somebody said yeah
you're right I think a romance she took
over the rabbit right it seemed like
because the trailer we saw Yes had those
that flavor yes so I'm thinking also my
Intrigue is if she's a ravager now and
then we got rocket they all are in the
new outfits yeah I saw her with them too
she didn't ravage her gear that's what I
thought right so that wasn't a fever
dream okay
five months ago and I can't remember if
I saw that in a comic room in real life
because I read too many Comics but um
the outfit uh mirrors Rockets outfit
even though it obviously is Comic Canon
like the reason they're doing it is for
Comic Canon yeah what if something
happens to Rocket they all want him to
feel like families they dress like
rocket like I could see that being a
thing so ravagers with them at some
point that's what I'm curious about not
but they've always dressed similar you
know even in Guardians volume two at the
end of the end of volume two they get
the same suits but now that it's rocket
suit is what I'm saying Rockets always
have the closest of the comics yeah so
we're gonna see it as a comic suit but
what if in storyline there's a reason
they're always dressing like rockets
immemorialism well he's there but I'm
saying what if they're going on a
revenge tour and they're trying to show
family you know what I mean like yeah
so that way he's not alone we're
dressing like I'm saying there's a Canon
reason beyond that yeah of course can I
ask a basic bechtold question here when
they're all leaving the ship in those
multi-colored uh suits with the white
dots what is that all about they're all
wearing like their own space suits like
I mean but that's not like there's not
that's why you don't nipples they're
playing Among Us I think they kind of
look like that but I'm like wondering do
you think the colors are significant to
something like what we haven't seen
those suits before right where they all
walk out in a different yeah color of
the world that might be a situation
where if this like flesh thing is it's
part of the high evolutionary Planet you
want to play the building yeah and
they've snuck in and maybe this is the
suits that his crew because they did
look kind of cartoonish to me like I
mean it's a very artistic choice I also
think it kind of mirrors the first
film's yellow suits right that was a
prison break maybe oh yeah right there
in a prison at some point uh Drax has
been like shot in the chat so I feel
like there's another again Canon reason
for that type of suit and that uniform
to be there's this sequence in the
trailer where uh Peter pushes a figure
it's in like a white suit right up a
window and they're tumbling we couldn't
see who it was yeah but maybe that's the
same facility where like a person
empowers in white and all the underlings
are in like different colors do noting
like which section and they could be
trapped in the high evolutionaries right
like later also what hit Drax in the
chest because we saw in the in the
holiday special you could shot about 95
times this is nine millimeters what hit
him in the chest to cause that little
crater yeah and did he still laugh uh
samill battenfield sending a Super Chat
saying the planet thing looks like the
high evolutionary is using the power of
a Celestial oh yeah reminded me of ego
making his Planet it did occur to me
that like if they are building if he's
building something on a cellular level
but it's a it's a Celestial cells would
be big right again where does orange
have come in right yeah because we're
definitely going to go into celestials
now yeah we're definitely doing that for
sure and the comic books like you should
have been reading the the celestial like
is where the Avengers have been living
like there's there's that event like
this is what I think Eternal zens with I
think that is going to be uh you know a
big basis and we also still don't know
how the 10 Rings tied out all this so I
I think what is the 10 rings are
quantumania thing I think I think that's
the beacon at the end of ten Rings The
Beacon they're sending out is to the
quantum realm because if you look at the
trail of quantumania you see the Rings
but I'm wondering if celestials built
the Rings in the first place or or if
the Eternal built the Rings in the first
place I'm wondering if all that together
in some way okay I can see that I mean
just so there's there's a backstory for
those everything everything
interconnected all connects so like I'm
wondering if we're gonna get any more of
those like little Easter eggs of that in
here I don't think we find it out in
Guardians but I could see more of those
little like seeds planted how low do you
think this movie is going to be six
hours definitely it's at like over two
and a half right close to three yeah I
think he wants a lot out of this yeah
it's gonna hurt me I'm gonna give it to
him here's the problem remember
Guardians 2 was long and it was a lot of
exposition and it made a lot of people
upset
because it was like some of some of the
scenes that we had with Gamora nebula
some of the scenes with Peter and ego we
all felt like it could be cut down but
the tick tockification of film is not
acceptable like I think James Gunn's
gonna have the Integrity to make movie
he wants no I get that but so I think
James finishing a thing he's not going
to care about like don't read the
internet like I mean he's gonna make the
story to finish him on this one these
characters yeah okay speaking of time
and like the movie's plot Mary Smith
sent in a question asking what time in
the movie do you think the Guardians
will reunite Gamora around the beginning
the middle or the end that's a good
question I think simultaneous missions
in the middle I think I think ravager
Adventure team up in the middle yeah I
think they keep crossing paths yeah they
keep crossing paths Peter keeps trying
to get with her like yo you love me
eventually and she like get the [ __ ]
away from me and like those yeah that
never works guys don't do that to women
right and this is like it's an
interesting position with like Groot who
we're calling swole group these days man
because James Kenneth pointed out that
grid is not the group from the first
movie it's it's he regrows it regrows
yes but it's not the same person or the
same being it's a new being like yeah
yeah absolutely yeah Theory uh and this
is like Gamora is not the same Gamora
right she she was up to a point but
doesn't have the same Bridge because
she's 24. yeah she's 2014 Gamora uh so
I'm wondering if like you know because
they also have the Bowie in this right
where's the Milano we didn't see the
Milano get destroyed walk it sold it
Rocky told it I wonder if like gamora's
took it yeah or something oh my God like
Peter wouldn't leave her alone and she's
leading the ravenger she's like take
that ship yeah get him away from me or
something like that yeah because it does
seem like we see lots of shots of
nowhere it looks like in this too
they've definitely set a base on nowhere
now I love that they've kind of upped
Cosmo he's finally talking he's got
Telecom the posters got Cosmo on it the
whole Guardians team it's a bigger team
because it's literally the guardian's
one poster but instead of five of them
it's like nine of them now the whole
family so I also that's another
what if the only one that survives is
groot's grandson then because remember
every time no every time dies another
group Sprouts up what if all of them and
that's they like Baby Groot I mean we
are Groot is would be the first time he
says it because I am Groot is all he
said and then this would be his first we
have rude to be here in the trailer
that's true he's a teenager
he's a he's a 24 year old douchebag
that's in the gym trading too much
pre-workout and sitting on the bench all
day not doing anything yeah I spend 24
hours on the toilet he says stunks
saying I am swole Groot okay uh he also
said hi evolutionary is about to kill a
few sadly it's gonna happen by Drax and
Rocket uh gonna sacrifice themselves I
mean Peter's crying has got to be over
the death of someone yeah that was too
extreme I think uh Jacob Smith saying
I'm honestly scared looks like Groot and
Star-Lord might die in the end so many
of our Guardians might die I mean I'm
right there with you man uh mookie
saying does Adam Warlock know magic
let's talk about Adam
good yo he look good he looks good I
mean all we know is that uh uh Aisha
made him we don't know but we don't know
if Aisha made him alone right we don't
know if Aisha had help from a high
evolutionary and we also know that James
got his number one and put a movie since
the first one yes and that's another
reason I was speaking of like the length
of this movie like all the stories he's
wanted to tell he knows he's done with
these characters whether or not they all
die or not right so I think you're gonna
have a lot of run time yeah I mean I'm
buying into this tragic film now
I just gotta cut the budget folks and we
gotta get rid of some of these I'm gonna
see it alone though I can't go with the
whole team also I can't let you guys see
me crying like that I wouldn't want I I
know Hugh Jackman's coming back for
Wolverine I'm very excited about it
obviously but I also there's a certain
amount of like physical like duress on
your body to play these characters this
long and I like yeah
I thought it was you Jazz huge Jackman
but like I feel like Paul Rudd like you
know he may look Immortal but he's
mortal and like you wouldn't want dude
to have to train like is a vampire on
the level of Pharrell and Smokey
Robinson dude for real skincare routines
it's just whatever that is it's just
imagine how old is 70.
836 years old
listen
how old do you think I am 9 307 of my
skincare days vicious I'm 15. shall we
just added more like no magic yeah no
magic
and I'm talking magic Anya Taylor Joy
from the New Mutants movie okay okay I
think he does they know each other
you out oh I gotta go you gotta go now
all right okay Courtney Scott brings up
a great Point what's going to be warlock
story without the Soul Stone what is
this Stone in his head
the creature we see in this it's it
looks very similar to the creature from
Guardians 2 that going after the annulax
batteries right involved with the uh the
pretty people the pretty golden people
The Sovereign that creature if I
remember correctly can travel through
Dimensions right it's an inner
Dimensions
creature is this like a stone from
another Direction exactly what I was
saying because Loki showed us remember
in the TV8 there's tons they're
paperweights so this could be a soul
Stone from again yes everything it
brings up the theory that the Infinity
Stones can't come back but I think that
if you have it it doesn't open up this
whole Infinity Saga but obviously in
other universes
right there in the tvas
yeah oh awesome take them out of their
universe so like if this was Adam
Warlock would have to be not from our
universe or you know what I mean like
right so if you move or the high
evolutionary figured out how to change
it around it's again this is a higher
revolutionary
the the Russo's established that the
destroys
right but their powers still exist right
they've just been kind of atomized
atomized into the universe but they're
still there maybe Warlock and the
sovereigns have found a way with the
stone to kind of draw the Soul Stone
power yeah and focus it that kind of
it's not like four Stones
Capital H three yes five lowercase j you
know Adam you can change that Adam
I just take a picture of it and then I
just read it off my phone
Adam Warlock is my 75 year old Aunt uh
here's a great thing uh we have not
discussed in Jay bomber 44 is angry
about it no he's saying why is no one
talking about nebula caring Star-Lord on
nowhere as if he's dead and they just
returned at the end of the film I'm sure
he's not dead in that sequence but I
think he does he's like kind of just in
a T-shirt and pants much like he's
dressed at the end of this trailer when
they're having that quippy exchange uh
with Drax so whatever they're going to
do there maybe it doesn't turn out so
well he looks pretty beat to answer J
bomber's 44th question I think the
reason that that's placed at the end
like he's dead is for James Gunn to make
you think he's gone he's dead because
remember we know people are dying
everybody's just like we keep assuming
the same too right Groot and drags
Gruden drags yes Star-Lord made that but
that may not be the moment I think it's
one of those famous Marvel trailer
moments in reverse and what we're seeing
is the middle of Peter Quill giving a
hurricane Rana to nebula and like what
we're just seeing it in reverse though
so when you play it forward word he's
about to viciously use his legs I love
the way the finger motion to do it yeah
or what if it's not even in the movie I
I think there's a fair amount of time
yeah there's tons of stuff in the
trailer that was not that's not in the
movie I think both Ant-Man and Guardians
have stuff that we're analyzing that
will never actually be used well well
this film reestablish uh Neymar's bulge
do we think I hope so do they think they
find it blue justice justice for his
balls yeah I think the blue Rays give
his blood balls yes uh uh I mean give us
the Bulge cut Drew in the chat also
pointing out you know he's asking were
they drawing blood from Quail that's
what I think that black liquid is
because remember at the end of the uh
the second film when he's able to wield
the because he's you know half God uh
through ego we do see like the black
veins and stuff I think maybe they use
him to like high evolutionary wants his
blood and he uses that to corrupt I
think that's his big like Power movement
right right that's that's the juice he
needs that's beautiful
what a day folks we're going to be
talking about all these Revelations of
the next coming days and weeks and years
as we wait for these films to come out
uh thanks to our super Chatters today uh
Tyler and Eve Harris sending in Super
Chat Caleb Jacobs is the dollar Destiny
Indy's final Adventure I hope
[Music]
uh just to get it over the professional
thanks so much uh uh Marshall off axes
fpv sending in a super chat
um Logan Lauer saying I hope Marvel
could pull a magnificent seven and all
the Guardians fall once oh
slowly lose them throughout the movie oh
my God oh my God powerful stuff uh that
would be sad and Wolverine Wolverine
Wolverine Wolverine sending a super chat
I hope I am allowed to read this woot
woot the big hit is Sans Queen Lulu on
my screen trash bag buff
ered a dollar super Chatters today thank
you for everyone hanging out with us
live today on this big big news
talk about until this all happened we
thought we'd be talking Transformers all
day yeah then everything just started
dropping everything started dropping
they got jealous
out there big news day in Disguise or it
could have been maybe maybe Paramount
got the word from somebody and Disney
was like hey they had to get an
evolution about 10 o'clock because you
don't I remember yeah
Paramount
be sure to like And subscribe this video
if you haven't already come see us on
Sunday yes come see us Sunday if you're
in the LA area for Comic-Con La there'll
be huge announcements there I guarantee
you but we'll be doing a live break room
10 30 a.m won't be on the internet you
got to be live to see it folks uh thanks
for tuning in today and join us here
tomorrow at the very same time uh like
we said uh Eric and when you have a
reaction out for Indy five trailer uh uh
there'll be a reaction out for the
Guardians of the Galaxy trailer uh
Anna's got a breakdown of the Super
Mario Brothers trailer she found so much
stuff in there I cannot believe it uh
and we're gonna there'll be breakdowns
for these trailers lots of stuff gonna
happen on the channel be sure to come
back tomorrow we love you guys thanks
for hanging out with us Breakers rumors
trash bags all of you adios have a good
rest of your day goodbye
[Music]